hi welcome to three scary games I'm so
happy you could join me on this journey
we're about to take as so many joyous
things that I want to show you in these
games so turn out your lights get some
snacks and prepare to feel the joy of
the scary games
ah
Oh Gavin Eisenbeis my beautiful paper
smile isn't it beautiful
yes I think so long ago there was an
island ruled by a kind just king his
people did not know its name but they
knew his face he was known all the way
to the edges of his kingdom and lived in
mighty fortress his love for his people
exceeded that of any other ruler to ever
live but that despite all this there was
one citizen who did not appreciate
everything the king had done but the
king would not accept opposition I sure
does sound like a fair and just king Oh
interesting fun so this is what I
consider to be a very stylized and
interestingly stylized game it reminds
me I forget the name of it right now
Oh No neverending nightmares in in a way
it reminds me of the the artistic miss
of neverending nightmares combined with
a few other horror games that I played
in the past this is just a demo but
might be pretty cool
chapter one my beautiful escape and my
escape will be beautiful this escape
about to be the hahahaha
that's a beautiful paper smile you got
there every day we hear one prominent
voice it's the voice of the authorities
whoa
right cool
they tell us that happiness is life
right they tell us that sorrow is death
they restrict our minds and emotions in
bliss they allow us to prosper but in
depression they allow only torment by
night I hear a different voice it is the
voice of the lost child whom I cannot
see instead I see another figure the
lost child wanted get out escape leave
this place okay as I sleep these words
run through my mind with pleasure
sure pleasure Oh joyous awaken all
joyous awaken all right its Paper Mario
up in this hi how are you doing it's
good to see you're awake did you have
any dreams last night yes the lost child
visited me again in my sleep what did he
tell you the authorities are weakening
our chances of escape are increasing the
coming of our desertion makes me more
fearful of the authorities they have
become severely harsh in recent days I
have worries as well we must observe any
opportunities right
everything about this makes me
uncomfortable AB coat scary oh I'm going
nuts oh hey alright bud Oh following me
you following me dude you following me
dude hey dude you following me oh hi
damn a today inventory I like that
that's cool I got a a white ticket could
be used to watch live entertainment
one of five why do I go to feed why gots
the goat foot why do I gots goat foot
the horrible malady of goat foot the
cell door is still locked looks like I
gotta find another ways out so oh oh joy
is perceived to Daly chambers that was
weird there was like a wall bill is
coming up before that a noon sment
happened all right
oh hey dudes hey dudes everyone's so
happy do the happy dance
doo-doo-doo-doo and to the right and you
dance to the left and you dance all
around the world but you are never to
travel beyond this door alright good
thanks thanks bud door seems to be
locked door seems been locked door seems
to be locked door seems to be locked
door seems to be locked door seems to be
locked
oh hi how are you doing good day
are you prepared for today's chamber I
found it much easier than yesterday's
and I'm sure you will be fine you will
do fine thank you thank you so much your
your hair is lovely by the way
just help you can you help me thank you
dear children for coming I am I'm a man
your attendance has been filed please
enter the line to the left going to
today's chamber great good thank you
maybe it's just the internal one
bullying that's going on behind me but I
feel a little uncomfortable about
today's chamber ah something's telling
me that maybe I might not like it
hello fellow joyous have you been
sleeping well lately I often find myself
lying with strange murmurs in my head I
can't understand them but I smile
regardless hello joyous smile always
friend hi
did you hear the strange commotion that
made itself known to us this past night
it was likely the authorities but still
we did not fear I'm just gonna go into
the chamber here we go baby
choo-choo Oh into the joist chamber
train it's gonna be great guys oh it's
gonna be great
this is gonna be I I'm looking forward
to this I got a good feeling beyond
these doors are your testing chambers
for the day the darkness inside will
consume you if you do not have a light
concrete take with you a life a life a
light a light a life a life it will
provide light in the darkness as you
wander and keep you safe today you must
learn to use your life for it will help
you greatly in tomorrow's chamber use
its light to find an exit do not be
afraid do not cry smile always Tyler you
may enter oh boy I can't wait to use
this life I'm going to squeeze this life
to get light light life oh oh it's hey
you know it's kind of dark it's a little
dark life will enhance your spirit with
uncorrupted life and amid light in
darkness
oh I'm glowing maybe blast
oh hey righty-ho my goodness wasn't
expecting that
she's a mini mini Christmas I got the
light baby I got the light I shall fear
no evil though I'm walking through a
dark hallway
I shall not I shall not fear no evil I
love this style of this by the way I
hate it also but I hate it because for
you where you I'll punch you I will
I won't I won't not punch you hop I'll
do it try me buchiach just a big stick
that I somehow slammed into my inventory
plank cannot be equipped base cannot be
unequipped great
yeah buddy we've what happens if i take
off my light
that's not good
well not buy a ball that's a good Oh
should I be concerned about that Dad
yeah take it off come out what are you
what's the worst go let's go baby
oh the darkness is taking me well so the
lesson of the day
hey I've got my plank I still got my
wood anyway what was that about love and
joy and joy love loving joy I love joy I
love to love joy and I Oh know Lovejoy
all right sure cool great hello oh sure
sure sure so I just got to look out for
a disembodied arm with a key in its head
you know I think if I'd find a
disembodied arm with a key in its hand
my gamer instincts would have told me
such that that key might have been
important hence why they would not have
cut the arm off anyway that door seems
to be locked
I shall go with this way it ah
thine path has been illuminated for me
yes this boy walked glad they made these
chambers for me
[Music]
alright fine you don't think I'm gonna
go to the big glowy thing in the middle
here you're darn tootin I am there we go
there's a key oh my arm off it's my arm
they're gonna cut okay what what about
the UH may open a nearby door okay sure
we'll see what nor imperfection well you
don't know that imperfection is oh it's
not a statement of me is by you this
story continues torture oh oh oh should
I run I should run I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna run oh hi who are you where is
your face where is your smile
oh yeah I'm gonna run yeah I should run
yeah oh hold shift to sprint yeah I
better run - run Oh what oh that see it
is a what is a painless is a painless
death what is I don't know what you're
doing there okay buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy we you
love spinning get away from me you freak
you freak of nature
maybe not even nature I'm assuming I
gotta do the loop-d-loop so that I can
get back around and I gotta go to the
door on the other side that's what I'm
guessing this is all about and I'm smart
so I'm assuming that's absolutely
correct well which it is thank you very
much go away otherwise this will be a
very quick dead-end here chocolate
chocolate chocolate chocolate okay look
lunk
I'm a genius I'm a genius I'm a genius
guys may happiness flourish on you who
have prospered through the darkness what
happiness has left one for I see a child
with tears did you feel the darkness
clutching at your heart did you feel it
clutching at your soul you should have
listened to our instruction child please
guide her to her session so we're
children or is that a children are we
all the children
oh and looks like one didn't make it out
of the chamber
you children still smile and have
learned well you will see past this
night now travel back to your cell and
rest until you must enter tomorrow's
chamber it's just like a bunch of escape
rooms they've they've built escape rooms
for us and we just have fun we go oh
locked real oh you're not gonna wait
maybe maybe they'll come out maybe maybe
they might he could boo out the way
you're still following me buddy good
good everyone needs an accountability
that's what everybody needs you're never
to travel beyond this door Thanks
there's me nice kid good childhood
good upbringing all right great
there I go oh hey hey I am asleep now
but I am caught thinking of the world
outside this facility can we ever make
our way there I am unsure we can
accomplish this goal without the aid of
the lost child lost child are you here
will you speak to me yes child I hear
your bidding will you aid our escape a
figure abides within the halls outside
yourself the authorities may be misled
allowing need to traverse toward you an
opportunity may have shown itself
shall I awaken yes child do so as I
attempt to infiltrate your walls I am a
child why they do this to us I am awake
but too afraid open my eyes I cannot
leave without my friend why not
friend friend a friend
I don't like my friend I don't like why
have you woken me it feel it is time to
escape are you certain that the time has
come I spoke to the lost child and I
believe he will now help us I worry with
the thought of what the authorities may
do if we are caught but I will follow
you friend I won't leave you to venture
onward alone well sure I'm probably
gonna leave you behind
God why do you guys talk so weird
all right the door is locked lost child
will you help us children I am here I
will assist you briefly but I cannot let
the King find me here I have unlocked
your cell door so you may exit you can
unequipped your life for short times to
evade the authorities cameras if they
see your light for too long you will
surely be taken to your sessions so
tread with care I must leave you now
okay thanks thanks bud I'll do that
pick my face off all right cool you okay
when should I put what from when should
I put my light tooth back on it also
which direction if half I goeth from
whence Direction ease doth I go owes ma
many owes my bro's oh no I'm fine oh my
god this way I I am go this this thus
thus direction is thus and the way is
clear
creepy creepy creepy this seems nice
I'll go towards the lot easy perfect
perfect
perfect in every way perfect go away
demons go away
this facility 12 East Wing construction
it is requested by his perfection the
king that a new chamber be added each
facility this chamber shall act as an
addition to current teachings and
activities for the children it will be
separated into two sectors each to act
as a separate chamber for daily
instruction the first will be similar to
the previous fear chambers more details
to be released and follow-up
instructions but prepare cropping
supplies for set area for the second
sector pain reducing equipment will be
supplied please set up restraints
immediately for temporary instruction in
this chamber all rooms residing in the
East Wing must be cleared within 60 days
further notice an instruction shall be
delivered shortly boy that sounds
promising for the teaching of the
children that are here and that we care
about some children of the facility 12
become increasingly rebellious one has
related information after being caught
regarding a voice that ill instructed
him on a request of his perfection a
meaning must be held to discuss the
banishment of this entity entity you say
I found another card was I supposed to
was I supposed to be collecting those
because I weren't because that wasn't
because I torn out weren't not
collecting those at wasn't collecting
them perfectly honest
[Music]
oh well that's nice nice smile on that
one that's that's the good stuff
hello hi oh hi buck
hi bud how you doing got another ticket
yay good stuff good stuff hi update log
24 facility 12 body of the faceless is
repaired a voice gives aid to the
children okay
- Joyce becomes a full sample of
perfection useful okay one has been cut
great great subtle resistance got it
okay cool didn't quite get that one oh
the body of the faceless something about
the body of the faceless bub to be able
to boot there was probably something
important in there like a secret message
or a warning that I was gonna die
imminently but I didn't hear it so I'm
gonna pretend like it didn't exist in
that way I can live my life peacefully
okay cool bye oh this is the wrong room
oh I walked into the bathroom yeah but I
walked into the bathroom I went to the
bathroom have been killed oh my god I've
been murdered
I'm all the way back here screw you I
mean I guess that was very obviously a
trap and I should have I should have
known that was gonna Myrtle eyes me
however you're all [ __ ] okay so the
answer is don't go in there which seems
very clear and obvious now seems like
exceptionally obvious definitely
shouldn't have done that
hi
what's going on in here how y'all doing
good to see y'all here this room seems
to hold great importance do you notice
the screens among us we may discover
objects of good use in here search for
anything of a potential aid to our
escape all right you do that bud you
doth do that doth do it i doth go this
way
I hate it facility one to sell for two
three eight joists one eight nine one
joists one eight nine - Joyce - six five
nine day one arrival begin testing high
performance pass major experiments began
daily visual training failure punished
failure punished failure punished
success punished began cropping previous
training persists joists one eight nine
- incompetent replacement summoned Joyce
- six five nine arrival a one eight two
five signs of thought emotion not shown
Joey's two six five nine under
surveillance Joyce one eight nine one
under surveillance surveillance halts
cropping failure confirmed weird that's
a lot of days
[Music]
why do you rate numbers so dumb oh I
hear discussion in the adjoining room
Oh Oh child why do you wander why are
your eyes open have you forgotten how to
sleep if you're not child 4 we will
teach you how to sleep Oh rot ro o or uh
troll put you out of sleep forever okay
good job guys
thank you your friends gone my friend
has been taken I must follow them
immediately sure sure yeah sure sure
sure
yeah of course yeah of course rut wrong
no no no nope nope nope didn't see
nothing weird weird how there was
nothing there
weird weird huh okay I'm assuming they
went this way
I don't know for certain oh yeah they
did
hey come back here with my friend you
bastards Hey on the wake - I fine be
that way
No
get off me boy oh come back please my
friend hello no the authorities have
locked the door lost child are you
present will you help me find my friend
he's gone the authorities may return to
capture me as well I must get back to
myself you coward you cowardly coward
you cowardly coward you think oh wow
interesting the first two chapters
launched early access on June 19th this
game I like it a lot of style the demo
is a little slow but I feel like it
needs to be slow because it's
introducing a lot of the world and it's
building it a lot of potential here like
not a lot of like boo scares even though
it had some scares but just looking at
like the demo footage there I can't wait
to see what's gonna happen in the future
it's gonna be pretty cool I think it's
gonna be really really neat now moving
on
alright this game is called isolation
simulator
that's gluggy that's a lot of glugging
going on over there that's that's some
glugs that is some hefty glugs okay here
I go
oh no oh no oh no it's presentable
Liberty all over again oh no my heavy
foot where am I
what have I done what have I done Here I
am hello wait wait whoa whoa whoa what
does that weigh
hey hey stop it you're just making a
note hey cut it cut that garbage yeah
okay all right sure please beam up I
speeding up who's throwing garbage at me
who top dillhole you cut that out right
now
okay alright here's what you're gonna
flood the room with garbage is that what
you're gonna do okay this is a little
ridiculous wait I can climb the stream
of cups I can do it I just gotta climb I
gotta believe I got a blame what the
cups it's still snowing Cup thank you
I'd like to stay in my hole
all right am I free am I free to go okay
why would you be so silly why'd you do
that also this is just another thought
okay I'll go back in my room I guess
here here's I'll stay here right here
[Music]
understood my dude understood my dude
all right you changed this room out that
was fun that was good activity I like
that active ah not bad actually you know
they don't usually give me music it's
not my first choice but hey anything's
better than nothing oh we done
I can't look down alright yeah sure this
game is supposed to be about the madness
of isolation and I am feeling it oh no
oh not the cup storm again god damn it
the cups I don't need the cup stop
pissing cuffs for me I never thought I'd
have to request that I never thought I'd
have to use English to say stop piston
cups on me but if you could stop that
would be great
Clank clunk clang oh thank you
great good stuff oh no not really I
don't wanna play with you no no
daddy ladi Dadi
call me daddy or Lodi Lottie daddy
who are they daddy oh oh no I'm good
thank you
no thank you with the thing I don't want
to play all right good freak I don't
know what's happening
I'm imminently confused I'm
incredulously confused
Oh No why don't like it I don't like it
I don't like it okay
don't oh hi again Hey
losing the guys I'm losing it I'm losing
my mind I'm losing it
guys I'm losing it I get it I'm here
she's just gonna loop-the-loop the same
things as a Lupin an end to this
oh not this
I'm good thank you
it was good it reminded me of like very
early era experimental our games very
good no no I said exit I said quit I
said quit you bench I said quit let me
out yeah welcome to I was so hungry why
does that dresser have nipples oh no oh
no no I know this is okay so there's a
thing about Carville is turned into the
most monstrous entity in the history of
monsters oh no and I know what this is
what specific comic this is relating to
oh my god
this is so messed up what did I just get
an e icon over oh god oh no
lazuli lazuli Garfield you are some
loser nee
you don't know Garfield is I suppose
that's not a bad thing so I'm not gonna
mock you for it why do I know who
Garfield is I don't know oh no oh no oh
no no no this makes no sense you'll see
the truth soon I think Oh
[Laughter]
there you go Garfield yeah so the comic
comes downstairs everything's covered
like garlic
Garfield's everything every single
service and that's because Garfield ate
the house cuz he was so hungry it
doesn't make any sense they they made
this too well yeah they made it horrific
Lee well oh they did too good of a job
on this no Odie are you well that was
quick my god I have to show you the
comics though I'm not sure if this is
the one that likes started all this [ __ ]
but yeah so it's like you're John wakes
up steps up everything's coated in I
think actually maybe this was it because
the subreddit is called I'm sorry John
is this the first one oh my god maybe it
is they did too good of a job recreating
that and then it's spawned just a whole
nightmare lick see and put up like a
bunch of different creepy Garfield
versions of the creepiness that that's
become his lost control of being an
adorable cat that hates Mondays and
loves design yet that was three scary
games hope Garfield doesn't show up in
your nightmares or you don't get pissed
on with cups so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want more scary
games there in the description
lexy and jump scare them to where the
description is it's try to point down
there but in a scary way you know what I
mean no a very scary arrow pointing down
make sense okay cool that'll be good
thank you thank you for that
boy how scary oh good it's down there
more scary gates are down there so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]